hey what's up guys just in a fantastic  interview coming out real soon with my  man grant cardone  has their valuing would they billion to  get dude you guys are gonna love this  thing man  all real estate like we couldn't get he  wanted to go to the sales way but I'm  like let's talk real estate come on this  is the thing that will get you rich  it'll take care of your family I'm in a  mistake right now they've owned it a  thousand years a thousand years they've  owned this place why because this real  estate businesses don't last a thousand  years real estate no so you gotta love  the interview check it out because we  did a great job by the way thanks  brother appreciate that